ja hallo plexus einem interview erstmals
eine video sind echt geil und nicht von
höheren neue videos bekommen habe ich
immer noch sachen also weiter so
ja und dann zum 1 ich hab drei stück
die erste rede wie die typographie hier
kommen solche videos zu machen hat
jemand gesagt komm mach doch mal videos
oder mathematik
es gab es damals ein mädchen wollte ich
zeigen so hey ich hab ich bin ein
bisschen lustig hier guck mal was ich
kranken die baulich beeindruckend hat
sich dann daraus wickel dass sich
mehrere mich beeindrucken wollte und
geschafft genau mit dem beeindruckenden
war wohl eher nicht das ding aber
dadurch kam es dass ich - einfach nervt
die zweite frage
hättest du niemals gedacht hast du in so
kurzer zeit so viele abonnenten kriegt
weil du hast ja jetzt schon irgendwie
über 100.000 abonnenten glaube ich und
das in so kurzer zeit das ist ja schon
nicht selbstverständlich also
selbstverständlich ist es wirklich nicht
darfst du echt recht
ob ich es gedacht habe
in so kurzer zeit hätte ich nicht
gedacht dass ich so viele abonnenten
erreicht aber mich freut es nicht es ist
cool
und die dritte frage und die letzte
sitzung später vielleicht mal
schauspieler oder comedian mit eigenem
willen show werden und oder was sind
deine billig ob ich schauspielerin
werden würde wollen zu machen schon
warum nicht also ich will jetzt nicht
darauf ausgelegt dass ich genau das
machen will aber ich kann mir gut
vorstellen dass ich etwas mache dann
vielleicht mal irgendwann so voll fest
um eine sendung auf prosieben wo ich
kurz so diese drei stunden show wollten
ein guter
kurs gebracht